a lot of people ask me when I write
something critical about John McCain you
know do what any duty and my answer when
it's not well he ran for president is to
say nothing at all in fact he was
interesting the reason that I started
writing about drama came to begin with
is that I found him genuinely
interesting as a politician and as a
human being especially after his first
run at the presidency in two thousand
and I went on vacation to Mexico wanted
to bring some books I brought his first
two books as memoirs fate of my father's
and worth the fighting for and I found
the very interesting sort of American
texts that are unusual for a politician
this sort of candor and a lot of other
parts of it talking about chasing skirts
and and hopping over the wall at the
Naval Academy to get as much bows as he
could get his grubby little hands on all
that was kind of endearing and at the
same time there was a few themes that
went through these especially about his
ideas about government he thinks that
government should be used so that we all
can feel a giant a common sense of
national purpose and national identity
so that we are not cynical you know so
that we finally again have faith in the
higher institutions of government and
when you think about that as a purpose
for government itself government becomes
self-perpetuating if I'm going to use
the federal government to restore your
faith in the federal government what is
it that this government cannot do the
list goes on forever and this comes very
through very strongly in his writings in
such a way that I found shocking that a
it existed like this and then this is
what he believed but that more
importantly be no one had written about
it's bizarre to me that in an age of
Plenty when we can go back and read his
five best-selling books or read all the
speeches and participation zat the
debates and things like that where his
beliefs are there for the taking not
least of which the fact that he's a big
neoconservative on foreign policy it's
there it's fact what all this exists yet
the media in there treat
of him rarely even got into the idea of
what his general core philosophy is on
governance so I sensed an opportunity
and I started writing about them and the
rest has been if not history an
interesting project